après trois mois d'interruption le
championnat de football anglais reprend
ce mercredi
en france en revanche il est
définitivement arrêté une fin prématurée
dénoncé par jean michel aulas le
président de l'olympique lyonnais jean
michel aulas bonjour bonjour jean michel
aulas c'est avant tout un entrepreneur
en 1983 il fonde la cegid une société
spécialisée dans les logiciels de
gestion le football arrive après en 1987
cette année là où c'est par bernard
tapie il devient président d'un club
criblé de dettes et englué en seconde
division
l'olympique lyonnais à seulement 38 ans
ce lyonnais ne cachait pas ses ambitions
nous avons prévu deux hypothèses une
première hypothèse d'accession à la
première division dès cette année mais
aussi l'hypothèse où cette accession
serait reporté l'année suivant l'ol en
première division s'est fait en 1989 en
coupe d'europe dès 1991 dans les années
90 jean michel aulas devient un
personnage à part dans le monde du
football
pour certains c'est un visionnaire pour
d'autres un provocateur
l'homme d'affaires divisent je pense pas
que ce soit quelqu'un qui soit
fondamentalement aimé mal aimé le
président de l'olympique lyonnais
en tout cas jean michel aulas l'assument
et continue même ses provocations son
bouc émissaire préféré l'arbitrage
exemple en 1996 selon le dirigeant de
l'ol
l'homme en noir était responsable de la
défaite de son club en finale de la
coupe de la ligue contre metz c'est se
joue à trois fois rien l'appréciation
d'un arbitre san arbitres qui n'est pas
très chanceux avec l'olympique lyonnais
on doit lui porter la poisse j'ai
l'impression en 2007
nouvelle polémique après un match contre
toulouse alors qu'un de ses joueurs
vient d'être expulsé
il s'en prend encore l' arbitre pour le
président de l'ol hors de question de
toucher à son club
ce qui m'insupporte en ce moment cela la
réaction
on va dire anti lyonnais pour essayer de
faire en sorte que l'appli connaissent
soit prêt au top
si jean michel aulas tu es souvent au
coeur de polémiques il n'en reste pas
moins un président respecté par ses
joueurs à l'image de grégory coupet
gardien de but de l'équipe
toujours en 2007 le mérite d'un d'un
club comme l'olympique lyonnais c'est
d'avoir un dirigeant ambitieux comme
monsieur aulas et qui a su prendre des
paris des peut-être même des mesures à
l'époque je pense qu'elle a plus d'un
qui qui devaient se dire qu'il allait
s'en tirer tout seul au bout du compte
voyant qu'il en est là aujourd'hui
jean michel aulas est toujours à la tête
de l'olympique lyonnais
mais pour combien de temps encore en mai
dernier il a laissé sous-entendre tout
pourrait passer la main d'ici quatre ou
cinq ans avec un successeur bien précis
en tête
l'ancien basketteur tony parker
[Musique]